when I write my scripts you know I start  with the first scene and then just go  through the story now normally  when I do a movie  yeah I have more or less  the story worked out  what I've learned is  that little mapping out of more or less  what happens in the story really only  applies till the middle of the story  Because by the time you get to the  middle of the story well now you know so  much more before you ever started  putting pen to paper I mean now I know  who these people are now now I am these  people these characters I am them they  are me now I'm I I truly know who they  are and now I've invested in this world  to such a degree that the hope is by  the 40 Mark or the 50 Mark that the  characters just take it from me and then  from that point on they're writing the  story wow